foreign
yes more okay that was good she's the
king of the freaks whenever Kamala
speaks
yeah our favorite cackling goofball VP
is at it again doing what she does best
making America pray that Joe Biden stays
healthy
today she spoke at a round table event
for labor and civil rights leaders in
D.C attendees wish the round table had
instead sharp edges so that they could
use it to kill themselves
their mission to explain the challenges
and rewards of artificial intelligence
and just like Dana trying to board a
roller coaster it just wasn't happening
I wonder is AI kind of a fancy thing
it is AI is kind of a fancy thing it's
first of all it's two letters it means
artificial intelligence but
ultimately what it is is it's about
machine learning
and so the machine is taught
and part of the issue here is what
information is going into the machine
that will then determine and and we can
predict then if we think about what
machine what information is going in
what then will be produced in terms of
decisions and opinions
um that may be made through that process
well at least we know she's not the one
on coke
[Laughter]
speaks to that room full of adults like
they're a child that just pooped its
pants
maybe that's how she talks to Joe but
you know the rest of us we're still
confident and coherent but we are
grateful she told us what AI stands for
but why stop there
there are so many fancy words out there
FYI three letters
and it means for your information
A-Okay stands for a
okay
Scuba
means South Cuba l-o-l
which means laugh out loud I really get
that one
foreign
TGIF
which means tall geckos in France
BYOB means it's almost time for your
meeting with Nancy Pelosi
JB
means I'll be president soon enough
[Applause]
cat is it her fault that she can't
really explain A.I she's lazy
it's not her fault that she's lazy I
don't is she though or yes like is this
any of this real
it like is stuff like that makes you
feel like we're living in a simulation
right because you know like we're just
having fun with her character or
whatever right because the old what's
the alternative that that's her doing
her best yeah yeah she talks like a kid
in grade school who was assigned a book
report that has to be a certain number
of words yeah yeah and they're like in
this essay I will
and it does they're just trying to get
to the word count because that's truly
what it sounds like she doesn't she
doesn't say anything she did she spent a
lot of time and she said nothing yeah uh
Dana uh uh why do you think they put her
in charge of AI is that They Don't Know
Jack about AI they don't care now
remember her husband was going around
the White House complaining that she
wasn't getting serious enough
assignments and because she had blown
off the Border issue then they gave her
space do you remember she had space she
had space in her portfolio right and
also she has voting rights that's also
something that the Democratic party is
pretty unhappy about they feel like they
haven't gotten anything on that so they
decided to give her AI the great thing
though that she doesn't understand is
that she could just delegate all of this
this is what you're supposed to do you
get put in charge of something then you
make other people do it right that's the
best exactly that's what you do when you
get in power uh Joe thoughts I don't
think anyone has ever said Kamala can
you dumb it down
that's funny she
you know what I like so I like about
that they really weren't sure
there you go do we applaud or don't we
we don't really applaud that much for
jokes so let's give it to him well
she she somehow started by saying AI
it's two letters and then went downhill
from there yes I think there was nowhere
to go but up so I think it's a pretty
good example of someone who could have
used artificial intelligence to write
her little presentation on artificial
intelligence she refuses to do the work
and she believed like this is I mean a
lot of people can can skate I by charm
and and persuasion but she can't because
it's so obvious Tom I mean you always
you know you're always come prepared
look at you now with your little your
little handkerchief and your tie that's
right that's right Greg
just looking a little you're looking
skinny and I'm worried no no you look
like uh you look like um uh uh Kevin
Spacey after doing a hot sauna
wow
[Laughter]
but I think she might prepare though
right I think she does I get the sense
she does a lot of reading but she
doesn't retain it because when she
speaks she has the quality of like she
doesn't know where she's going and she's
just relying she's choosing the word
based on the previous word she just said
yes you know what I mean she's like
autocorrect yes it just keeps going and
it reminds me of an exercise that I did
in college we were we did an improv
exercise where the two partners get on
stage and you just have to say a word
and then the other person says it so
when she's doing it it's like two people
in dialogue she's like a i
is very
fancy
[Laughter]
she's just happy she got to the end of
the sentence you know
well done my friend except no one is
saying yes and yeah yeah they're like no
stop stop no stop coming up Summer slimy
summer furry my friends are back in a
hurry
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else